le genre humain
ô combien complexe dans un monde qui
interpelle plus d'un
forte tête aux têtes en l'air
personnalités en construction ou des
constructions ici une exposition
collective désir cannibale neuf peintres
et plasticiens guadeloupéens
samuel gélase à titre d'exemple leur
école on aime ou on n'aime pas
[Musique]
j'aimais à l'école je n'étais pas très
assidu j'étais assez river c d'où le
côté artiste un homme est très sensible
voilà donc ce portrait de classe à part
les petits plus de de la société en fait
tout le monde a les souvenirs de ces
photos de classe et dans une classe en
fait il ya plusieurs jeunes qui ont
diverses personnalités qui se sont si
les individus qui vont constituer la
société de demain
[Musique]
oui donc cette offre qui s'intitule
crimes contre l'humanité c
mais c'est une oeuvre qui fait partie
d'une série qui s'intitule negri side
l'expression qu'à inventer un critique
d'art guadeloupéen qui s'appelle
jousselin balton qui signifie [__] et
homicide
voilà donc si un travail sur la
dimension génocidaire de la traite
négrière
on travaille tend à s'ouvrir au monde en
fait il faut t'il de tout pour faire un
monde
ronald cyril jeune plasticien pour lui
pas question de se taire écrit pour dire
ce qui me mine c'est aussi ce qui
m'anime à travers la société donc
quelque part c'est une manière pour moi
de d'exister bien que je sois proche des
animaux et de la nature parce que j'ai
grandi à la dominique
il s'agit pour moi de questionner
l'homme de questionner l'homme à travers
sa relation avec l'autre mais de
questionner l'homme aussi à travers j'ai
envie de dire son intérieur
mais mon niveau du chapelet j'ai le
souvenir de mes grands parents comment
c'est un objet précieux entre guillemets
maintenant il ya des déplacements qui
sont faire les choses deviennent riquet
en banal et puis donc on a des jeunes
qui met des chapelets de toutes les
couleurs c'est tendance et fun désir
cannibale au coeur d'une société
guadeloupéenne seulement neuf jeunes
artistes jusqu'au 19 septembre à la
cuverie de l'habitation clément au
françois